katie is in Tennessee Dave if I have a
$300,000 mortgage debt should I still
only get 10 to 12 times my income and
life insurance or should I get more to
include that debt amount into 12 times
should cover your mortgage payment if
you're making your mortgage payment now
if your income now will pay your
mortgage payment and you get 10 to 12
times that amount
you know let's say that you make
$100,000 a year and you get 10 times
that that's a million dollars and you
die your spouse takes a million dollars
an investment if it makes 10 percent it
creates $100,000 so $100,000 income is
$100,000 income and you were paying the
rent you were paying the mortgage with
$100,000 before and now you got a your
spouse has got $100,000 off the
investment alone and that's what 10 to
12 times will do roughly it's it's a
rule of thumb it's not an exact science
but it's very close and it makes sure
that you buy enough life insurance and
you buy time life insurance you never
buy cash value insurance that way you
can afford to get enough for one thing
the second reason is is it cash buy you
insurance all the different versions of
it or a ripoff and much better off doing
your investing in good investments